bonjour le mois dernier j'ai commencé à
vous parler de game of thrones parce que
c'était deux saisons est ce ma si on va
en reparler parce que c'est toujours de
saison mortels comme intro vrai mais on
est invité cette fois wade a rien à
envoyer un corbeau je suis personne
laisse moi tranquille
c'est une phase je pense bref c'est bien
joli de parler bâtiment mais game of
thrones est tout de même réputé pour une
chose la mort faire la mongolie c'est
juste une réutilisation de roche
loin de moi l'idée de vous faire une
liste exhaustive de tous les morts dans
game of thrones du style et vous voyez
est bien plus qu l'ordre de pk au choc
en 1237 il est mort exactement de la
même manière tous pareils ça serait long
et un petit peu inutile du coup j'ai
juste repris quelques passages marquants
de la série et on va surtout s'attarder
sur des assassinats des procès mortelle
des morts en temps de guerre et des
morceaux comme la dernière fois je
risque de spoil est elle une traîtresse
d'euros lors dix ans les flammes alors
vous êtes prévenus et c'est parti
[Musique]
deux assassinats dans la série ont
particulièrement marqué les esprits ce
qu'ils produisent et des retournements
de situation assez fou fou mais aussi il
évoque des événements historiques bien
celle où le premier c'est l'assassinât
de john snow pour la faire courte
john est nommé lord commandant de la
garde de nuit grâce à la manière dont il
a défendu le mur contre l'attack des
sauvageons menée par monster et aussi
grâce à ses copains qui font bien
campagne pour lui avez vous entendu
parler de john snow
malgré le silence des corbeaux bref pouf
le voilà commandant sauf que ça ne plaît
pas alister thorn déjà qui n'a toute
façon jamais pu blairer sa décision peu
après son élection de faire franchir le
mur au sauvageon restant pour s'allier à
eux et protéger plus efficacement et
sept couronnes contre les marchés en
blanc
chaque pas mal de monde et le rend
impopulaire auprès d'une partie de la
garde
en plus il propose de filer au sauvageon
des terres dans la région du don qui ne
se privait pas de piller allègrement
auparavant savoyard lee est enroulé vers
ville vieille veste raimon est mort
slash partie aussi selon si vous
préférez les livres la série et ça
laisse pas mal de place à ses
détracteurs pour un bon petit à thaksin
a dans la série cet assassinat est
particulièrement mise en scène au lit le
protégé de john puisqu'il avait nommé
son intendant personnel
l'atir dehors jusqu'à un poteau affiche
en traître il reçoit ensuite un coup de
couteau d'alice turn puis des conjurés
chacun leur tour avant de finir par owni
chacun déclarant pour la garde en
faisant leurs affaires des gars plutôt
rancunier dans cette mise en scène on
retrouve très clairement une référence à
l'assassinât de jules césar
je vais pas m'attarder sur cette
comparaison là parce que nota bene on
parle déjà dans l'une de ces vidéos dont
je placerais le lien dont la description
mais pour la faire courte césar est
assassiné en 44 avant jésus-christ
notamment parce que ses détracteurs
pensaient qu'il risquait de rétablir la
monarchie arômes
je peux la monarchie était aboli à rome
depuis des siècles nous en gardons un
très mauvais souvenir
alors quand jules césar s'est déclarée
dictateur perpétuelle certain vu rouge
il est aussi assez proche du groupe des
populaires est qu'ils sont plutôt pour
la solidarité ans d'opposition groupe d
optima tests qui sont attachés à leurs
privilèges et attachés au maintien d'une
vraie oligarchie de droit divin avec un
s
bref bouffe tout ça fait qu'il a pas mal
d'ennemis à rome ses ennemis
ourdissaient un complot de 60 à 80
conjurer menée par cailloux station
minus et parmi lesquels on trouve le
fils adoptif de césar bonus le 15 mars
44 avant jésus-christ ils sont une
trentaine à attendre césar au sénat au
port d'armes est interdite ils
s'assemblent autour de lui les mobilise
et l'assassinent de 23 coups de
poignards avant de se disperser
il s'agit d'un assassinat pas super
préparer pour la république qui me fait
toute manière pas de vieux os après ça
et pour leurs intérêts personnels aussi
les conjurés meurent tous dans les trois
années qui suivent et pas de leur belle
mort bon john snow s'est fait assassiner
jules césar s'est fait assassiner plein
d'autres gens aussi où est la référence
je ne sais pas - pas voir ce qu'ils font
les fouilles
la mise en scène dans les deux cas on a
un groupe de conjurés qui prennent leurs
ennemis par surprise et qui lui plante
chacun leur tour un coup de poignard
dans le ventre
la référence est particulièrement
marquante bien le personnage de holly
que john avait pris sous son aile pour
en faire potentiellement son successeur
qui rappelle donc brutus fall armand
colin l'autre assassinat plus tôt
marquant concerne europe stark lors des
noces book reding je passe un peu plus
vite sur les événements cette fois ci
parce que contrairement à ma vidéo sur
les monuments dans game of thrones qui
ont un background assez peu développé
dans la série et disséminés dans les
livres il est fort probable que vous
vous soyez prêt les noces pour en pleine
face
et de même pour les autres événements
j'aborderai ici qui sont déjà assez
clair rien qu'en regardant la série pas
comme l'histoire de la construction du
phare de villevieille
du coup une robe avait scellé une
alliance avec les frêles pour traverser
leur peau avec son armée mais en échange
il devait épouser une des filles ou
petites filles frey avait le choix
pas de bol pour le viol d'air il tombe
amoureux de talent et sa mayer dans la
série et de jane wasterlain dans les
livres à partir de là il est bien obligé
de frayer à nouveau avec les frais parce
qu'il a toujours besoin de leurs troupes
et de leur pont alors à la place ils
décident que son oncle et de murs
héritiers des tuileries épousera une
fille ferait on dit pas fraîche pour
comprendre à quel point leurs frais ne
gagne pas au change
en mariant sa fille et rob stark il
aurait eu une reine pas forcément de
tout était rose mais vous pouvez
toujours imaginer ce qu'ils voulaient il
aurait pu en profiter pour essayer de
pas mal s'impliquer dans la politique du
nord et de navarre alors qu'au lieu de
ça on lui propose juste une et d'italie
la grande famille noble du coin youpi
waldorf est donc une petite alliance
avec les lannister en secret reçoit les
staffs dans son château où tout le monde
fait ce soir game ans jusqu'à ce que
retentissent de la chanson des lannister
les pluies de casta maire qui annonce le
début du massacre
on peut penser que rob stark était naïve
de ce coin de pardonner aussi vite mais
les lois de l'hospitalité à westeros
font que si on partage le pain et le sel
sous le même toit
on est censé ressortir de ce toit en
toute amitié d'où l'importance de cette
scène où et muret s'est discrètement de
cacher qu'il s'est foutu limiers de
partout à travers l'histoire les
assassinats en plein repas sont plutôt
courant cissé avant le dessert c'est
vraiment dégueulasse ans 276 par exemple
l'empereur probus aurait invité les
généraux responsables de la mort de son
prédécesseur un grand banquet de se
retirer dans une autre pièce et de les
laisser se faire massacrer
on retrouve plus de ressemblances avec
les north pourpre dans l'assassinât
suivant en 749 abou al abbas aimerait
devenir calife à la place du calife
à cette époque c'est la dynastie
omeyyade qui règne sur l' empire d'islam
mais qu'à cela ne tienne il se fait
proclamer et force le calife omeyyade à
fuir en egypte dans une offre de
réconciliation en 750
il invite toute la famille omeyyade à un
grand banquet à damas au cours de ce
repas un poète soda il est invité et
déclame ne te laisse pas abuser par la
conduite et les démonstrations de
certains personnages 10
un gay ses apparences cache un mal
dangereux frappe de l'épée tient le fou
est élevé jusqu'à ce que tu ne vois plus
d'oméga sur la terre et là c'est le
massacre ce procédé nous rappelle pas
mal et plus de casse ta mère qui sont
utilisés pour annoncer le début du
massacre des stark chez les omeyyades un
seul parvient à s'enfuir en espagne et
font de l'émirat omeyyades de cordoue
mais à damas le pouvoir reste aux mains
des abbassides puis d'autres familles et
plus jamais des aux meilleurs le dernier
assassinat dont je vais parler utilisent
aussi ce procédé de temps dans cette
musique quitte annonce que tu vas
prendre cher nous sommes en 1440 en
écosse le jeune roi james ii est montée
sur le trône récemment mais n'a que neuf
ans il est sous la régence deux soeurs
douglas mais ce dernier mort de la peste
deux autres personnages sur crichton et
c'est oliver stone qui n'est pas un
goéland assure la régence mais craignent
encore que le fils de douglas williams
ne nuise à leur projet williams à 15 ans
5000 hommes à ses ordres et le roi james
de l'ader kristen et livingstone invite
donc william douglas et son petit frère
à un banquet et on commence à connaître
la musique ils sont très bien accueillis
honoré et même le jeune roi est présent
jusqu'à ce que le son des cornemuses
retentissent et à l'époque ça signifiait
pas qu'on allait pouvoir danser labouré
mais plutôt la guerre d'après certains
récits desservant aurait aussi apporté
une tête de taureau noir aux deux
garçons un symbole de mort +63 mise en
scène plutôt explicite quoi au cas où
ils n'auraient pas bien compris alors
que le jeune roi james ii est plutôt pas
d'accord avec ce qui se passe mais pour
rappel il a que neuf ans les deux glaces
sont saisis par des gardes en est à
l'extérieur pour y être exécuté ce dîner
reste connu comme le black dinner ou
plaques de glace à ne pas confondre avec
le black pudding c'est du boudin
plusieurs autres assassinats d'autres
ont pu influencer de george martin
on pourrait parler d'une tentative de
massacres pendant un mariage à fait
morte mort du massacre de glencore du
massacre de stockholm
bref protégez vous manger seul fall
armand colin tyrion lannister à ce
manque de bol de subir deux procès au
cours de la série tout en étant innocent
à chaque fois son manque flagrant de
karma nous permet d'aborder la manière
dont sont gérés les procès dans
l'univers de game of thrones et surtout
comment ils sont souvent réglés
le premier procès de tyrion a lieu dans
la saison une lorsqu'il est accusé de la
tentative de meurtre contre baham stark
il est alors capturé par catherine stark
est conduit en prison sans passer par la
case départ au zerg et
pour être jugé par leila haring le
procès n'est pas super équitable devions
à que sa parole pour le défendre et sans
qu'elles risquent de finir au fond du
trou et au fond de ce trou là il n'y a
pas vraiment de feu du coup ils
invoquent le pif paf c'est pas moi des
procès médiévaux l'ordalie ici un duel
judiciaire qui permettra au dieu de
décider qui est le vrai coupable
et effectivement coup de bol c'était pas
lui la deuxième fois il est jugé dans le
cadre de l'assassinât de joffrey
baratheon lannister ça dépend encore un
assassinat pendant un mariage
bravo les valeurs et la cie la décadence
un geoffrey était un petit con même pas
un vrai baratheon il aimait les
prostituées simplement pour les
zigouiller bolena terre elle préférait
un genre plutôt aussi lui offrir un peu
de vin pour le détendre faraman
coulisses mais puisque thirion été
publiquement en froid avec son neveu que
sercel des tests et que c'est un
prétexte parfait pour se débarrasser de
ce lait mister un peu gênant on décide
que c'est lui le coupable
sentant qu'il risque d'être condamnée et
provoqué par le témoignage de chez à son
encontre
il demande à nouveau un duel judiciaire
en espérant que ce qui a déjà marché une
fois marchera une deuxième fois pas de
chance cette fois son champion en
verrines et tout aussi préoccupé par sa
vengeance personnelle et terminant
pastèque
si on s'était trouvé dans notre monde de
toute façon ce duel n'aurait
probablement pas pu avoir lieu de cette
manière le déséquilibre entre l'armure
de la montagne et celle de berin et le
recours aux poisons par ce dernier
aurait été interdit les armures l'armée
même l'aiguisage de la lame était
souvent contrôlés et devait être le plus
authentique possible et pas trop de
faire plus dans game of thrones des
dieux judiciaires sont une alternative à
une forme de procès plus traditionnel
avec des juges et des témoins l'accusé
peut demander à être plutôt jugée par
dia judiciaire et on sent que ça se
produit surtout quand il sent que le
procès ne va pas tourner en sa faveur
il ya quand même quelques restrictions
l'accusé doit appartenir à la noblesse
accusés et accusateurs peuvent décider
de se battre eux mêmes ou désigner un
champion qui doit être volontaire le
combat peut exceptionnellement prendre
la forme d'une grosse baston à 7 contre
7 judicieusement appelé le jugement à
sept rapports à la religion locales
durant le moyen-âge il existait
plusieurs moyens de rendre la justice
celle-ci se baser sur le serment et les
organes qui pouvait consister en rester
debout sur une croix le plus longtemps
possible tenir des charbons ardents
plein de joyeusetés qui visait à prouver
l'innocence de l'accusé qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
tu es coupable logique des duels
judiciaire correspondent aux ordalie
bilatérales qu'on appelle aussi doué
loubet loum l'accusé et l'accusateur
doivent alors s'affronter devant les
autorités laïques et que le plus
innocent gagne cette pratique est
pourtant de plus en plus critiquée par
l'église qui y voient une
instrumentalisation de la justice divine
les ordres d'ali sont interdites en 1855
par le concile deviennent même si elle
reste en vigueur jusqu'au xiiie siècle
elles sont ensuite interdite par louis 9
ans 1258 et le droit au marais apparaît
peu à peu merci de reconnaître notre
supériorité dans la série on retrouve le
même schéma puisque thommen interdit les
duels judiciaire juste avant le procès
de sa mère il a influencé par le grand
moineau qui voudraient rétablir une
vraie justice divine
ça pourrait un peu les plans de cersei
si vous aimez les ordalie angle droit
avait aussi fait une vidéo sur le sujet
donc je mettrai le lien en description
ce que le partage c'est beau on en
arrive donc au mort qu'on est pour ça je
vais pas m'attarder sur certains
personnages des cédants sur leurs
toilettes mais plutôt vous parler de
cochons et autres ports cité robert
baratheon adore chasse et il adore aussi
l'alcool et ça arrange bien cersei en
passant par son écuyer l'antenne
lannister elle fait empoisonner son vin
pour faire placer sa mort pour un
accident de chasse seulement dans
l'histoire sert silent cell ne sont pas
les seuls responsables de sa mort
redonnons la place qui lui est due aux
sangliers sous l'emprise de son va
empoisonner robert baratheon voit ses
talents de chasseur bien diminuée et ses
one two même de sa troupe pour tenter de
mettre à mort la bête
pas de bol le 100.000ème se laisse pas
avoir si facilement et en broche robert
avant de mourir baratheon à la broche le
sanglier n'est donc pas le seul
responsable mais même si des doutes sur
la mort du roi apparaissent très tôt la
version officielle est bien l'accident
de chasse ces récits de roy tués par des
cochons sont assez courants dans
l'histoire les nobles pratiquant la
chasse depuis bien longtemps
en tant que loisir de riches et en tant
que symbole de puissance
c'est le cas de louis 5 qui meurt en 987
écrasé par son propre cheval après que
le sanglier qu'il essayait de chasser de
lui fonce dessus
sa mort met fin à la dynastie des
carolingiens successeur est donc une
cape et le destin porcin ça charmant
suite sur les philippe philippe de
france le fils de louis 6 legros était
destiné à devenir roi après la mort de
son père était déjà associé au pouvoir
dès l'âge de 13 ans cette préparation à
l'accession au pouvoir ne dure
malheureusement pas longtemps le 13
octobre 1131 alors qu'il se promène à
cheval dans paris son cheval croise le
chemin d'un cochon plutôt nerveux se
cabre fait tomber le prince
les cras sous son poids philippe meurt
peu après et le trop de revient ensuite
à son petit frère
selon certains historiens et notamment
phil et pastoraux qui a écrit un livre
sur le sujet la mort du prince a
plusieurs conséquences sur le royaume de
france
elle place sur le trône le jeune louis 7
qui était destiné à devenir
ecclésiastique comme c'était souvent le
cas des secondes et il connaît donc mal
l'exercice du pouvoir et ça se ressent
pendant son règne mais ça sera une
histoire trop long de la raconter
en plus il ya déjà un épisode de
confession d'histoire sur le sujet
décidément c'est la journée des partages
michel pastoraux et mais aussi la thèse
qui paraît vraisemblable pour plusieurs
historiens que la mort de philippe de
france par un cochon animal considéré
comme sale est un pur soit la raison
pour laquelle son père choisit par la
suite comme emblème la fleur de lys et
le bleu symbole de la vierge pour
essayer de faire oublier ce passage un
peu honteux disgrâce infâme
enfin quelques générations plus tard
philippe lebel se trouve lui aussi en
pleine partie de chasse en et 314 lorsqu
encore une fois le sanglier décidé de
charger son cheval le fait tomber et par
flo il est blessé mais surtout se
retrouve soudain incapable de parler et
pris de maux de ventre les médecins n'y
comprennent rien il meurt quelques
semaines plus tard et les chroniqueurs
sont partagés sur la responsabilité de
cette maladie étrange ou du sanglier
tu m'étonne qu'avec tout ça le sanglier
soit associée au diable avec nos
connaissances actuelles il est possible
que philippe le bel soit en fait mort
d'un avc fall armand colin game of
thrones c'est aussi la bagarre est l'une
des plus marquantes et la bataille de la
néra qui oppose l'armée de stanis aux
soldats de port réal stanis vient de
tuer son frère ennemi de récupérer tous
ses bannelings au passage et attaque
port-réal par le fleuve de son botté
thirion
mes mains du roi prépare très
minutieusement la défense de la cité
il renforce les murailles déplacent tous
les manteaux d'or accompagnée de
quelques trébucher catapulte et envoie
des tribus des collines dans le bois du
roy au sud de la ville pour empêcher les
éclaireurs de stanis de passes et
surtout il a un plan
ayant appris que certains il faisait
refaire le stock de feu grégeois de la
vie il réquisitionne le tout est en
charge 13000 peau dans les navires une
chaîne bloquent l'entrée du flop pour la
flotte de stanis et celle ci n'a pas le
temps de réagir lorsqu'elle constate que
les navires de la capitale répond d'un
drôle de liquide vert sur leur passage
boum
la majorité de la flotte est détruite et
le reste débarque finalement à la porte
de la gadoue mai est repoussée cette
bataille et surtout l'intervention du
feu grégeois nous ramène chez les
omeyyades dont on avait vu la fin un
petit peu plus tôt et surtout au conflit
qui oppose le calypso lehman à
l'empereur byzantin anastase 2 au début
du viiie siècle le conflit entre les
deux empires est ouvert depuis un moment
et le calice souleymane prépare un
nouveau siège de constantinople la ville
à prendre ça va ce n'est pas byzance non
plus bas ainsi mettre à jour un peu pas
de bol pour le khalife
anastase est au courant pro champ est au
courant tel un petit riant des temps
modernes y fait rehausser les murailles
de la ville prévoit des stocks de
nourriture et chasse une partie de la
population ce qui est moins sympa quand
on sait que les armées de souleymane
avance en pillant tout sur leur passage
au printemps 716 le siège commence et
les troupes du calife sont beaucoup plus
nombreuses que celles de constantine à
la ville n'a plus aucun moyen de
ravitaillement et semble perdu mais
quelle est cette lueur à l'horizon dans
d'elf le feu grégeois les byzantins
mettre le feu aux navires du calife
et c'est le cas cette victoire permet
aux bisons part de gagner du temps de
s'allier avec les bulgares pendant
l'hiver 717 et de repousser
définitivement les troupes arabes de la
région pour l'empereur anastase par
contre le destin est moins sympa une
révolte de l'armée le contraint à se
retirer du pouvoir avant d'être
décapités en 719 en même temps si on
suit le lien avec thirion on peut pas
dire que par réel lui sauterait
reconnaissant non plus d'avoir défendu
la ville le feu grégeois est donc une
arme connue de l'antiquité et du moyen
âge on le retrouve dès le 9ème siècle
avant jésus-christ chez les assyriens on
trouve ensuite pendant la guerre du
péloponnèse qui oppose en gros les
athéniens et les spartiates puis chez
les byzantins partir du 6e siècle
il est aussi présent en occident
m et xiième siècle était probablement
composée de mélange de résine de pin de
chaux vive de soufre de salpêtre
ou peut-être aussi oxyde de calcium ou
encore de pétrole sa composition exacte
reste inconnu ça explique probablement
sa disparition progressive
les armées arabes et bulgares qui
parviennent à s'emparer du feu grégeois
n'arrive pas à reproduire la recette et
la diffusion progressive de la poudre à
canon à partir du 14e siècle rend le
secret de la roussette du feu grégeois
moins importante mais il n'est plus
mentionné après la prise de
constantinople 2453 val armor glisse ça
veut dire quoi en fait
memento mori si on résume notre propos
très simplement jusqu'ici les gens
meurent et ce fait connu de tous est
résumé dans l'univers de game of thrones
par cette phrase simple voilà mongolie
cette expression orale et rien signifie
tout homme doit mourir et semble être
une devises courantes dans tout le
continent des choses puisqu'on la
retrouve aussi bien à bravo la réponse
habituelle et valeur de rs tout homme
doit servir que dans l'est du continent
puisque dan harris et miranda et semble
très bien la connaître
pour l'anecdote cette phrase peut aussi
se traduire par les puissances de la
sorcellerie dans le faux de tolkien
vallar signifie puissance en kenya et
mongole signifie sorcellerie en sindara
de des landes de la terre du milieu
frodon si on revient en ce sens premier
de cette phrase peut être perçue comme
une incitation à prendre conscience
qu'on va tous mourir un jour
au moyen âge on retrouve cette idée avec
la formule du memento mori contrat du
couramment par souviens-toi que tu vas
mourir
même si elle signifie plutôt prépare toi
à mourir oui car maury est au présent
merci bien cette formule devient très
populaire à la fin du moyen-âge
on la retrouve dans les représentations
de danse macabre puis de natures mortes
de manière générale si on trouve un
crâne dans une oeuvre de l'époque le
sens n'est pas très compliqué à deviner
tu vas mourir est à penser à d'abord tu
vas mourir tu es prêt à mourir ne pêche
pas trop tu vas mourir tu vas mourir
retrouvez tout aux offres de pompes
funèbres dans notre catalogue ou par
téléphone nous avons 6 0 6 0 6 0 6 0 6 à
partir du xvième siècle s'ajoute à cette
formule le célèbre carpediem qui incite
à profiter de la vie puisque comme
chacun sait
tu vas mourir enfin la mongolie voilà
j'espère que ces deux épisodes dérivés
de game of thrones vous ont plu j'aurais
pu aborder plein d'autres points mais la
vie est courte et des sujets historiques
nombreux donc la prochaine fois on
reviendra sur de l'histoire tout
simplement comme je le rappelle quand je
pense à écrire dans mon script vous
pouvez toujours vous abonner partager
commenter ou même faire un tour sur tipi
ou le type pour contribuer à mon travail
en donnant quelques piécettes si vous
vous à bientôt par la banque au kosovo
kengo challenger swedlove chez von
bomhard faut sauver je compte donc une
belle
[Musique]
jumeaux
nous avons été tous